I was sub G Q I'm Jerrod wrong and these
are my essentials this is my brush my
hair kind of goes from really long or
really short just back and forth all the
time so this kind of keeps it in control
so whether in short whether it's long
his fresh is smooth so it's a little
okay this way a little bit that way
right and I'll do a little turn so I get
the curls to puff then that's it that's
how I use my brush nope there's a big
difference between the regular brush on
the beer brush the beer brush is smaller
gets the actual little corners of the
face you know I'm saying if I use the
big Brush it kind of just have a big so
the smaller is much better it's more
contained it's cute or two it also looks
like a toothbrush so people ask me why I
put my toothbrush out on the train but
it's a beard brush that's my favorite
makes sense it's actually my rulers and
now it's mine
lip balm this is extremely key for me
because the amount of times I have seen
myself in a film or a show and I have
the most chapped lips I've ever seen
it's very embarrassing when I watch
myself I'm like Jared did you forget
your chapstick that day and I probably
did so now I don't forget my lip balm I
always like five times a day put on my
lip balm so my lips are not checked yeah
I think I just got put off to this like
a month ago it used to be the average
chapstick you know the regular one that
I had blistex and Carmack's I try
tomorrow really but this was my favorite
because it's kind of it kind of makes my
lips look really glossy after looks like
I just kissed somebody you know I always
have lips that look like they just got
kissed I did get it sex it's my sister
and we're gonna meet up tomorrow she
gave me a thumbs up she doesn't say many
words I'm like hey I can't wait to see
you oh my god it's been so long that's a
response but my phone I guess just like
everybody else is extremely important I
never leave without it because pretty
much my entire mental state is on my
phone in terms of family in terms of my
team and my career and the work I have
to do but I also make music so I write
all my music on my phone I actually have
it in the notepad section which is risky
because I don't want to lose all this
stuff but pretty much a ton of just
different ideas and lyrics and stuff
that I do and I'll just be in an uber or
walking down the street and I'll have an
idea and I'll just pull out my Notes app
and I'll just start typing so my phone I
cannot go without
[Music]
this essential is really close to me and
as special to my heart because it's my
it's my grandfather's watch
it's a Gucci watch I'm not sure the
exact year it's from but it's really old
and very vintage and it's kind of messed
up a little bit but he passed away three
years ago and I feel like a big reason
I'm here today is because of him and I
think he's watching over me and guiding
a lot of the decisions I make and the
moves I make and so I keep this in any
hotel room or any apartment I'm in I'll
keep it on the nightstand next to me and
I'll never wear I might wear it maybe
for a really special occasion but um the
plan is to really just keep it
everywhere and not wear it you know it's
all super special and I miss my grandpa
you know another essential of mine is
I mean it's clothing pretty much like
I've been trying to close shop a lot
lately because I'm getting tired of all
my old clothes and fall is coming so I'm
trying to find a whole new fall attire
including this blazer which is from
Banana Republic and I have not taken it
off since I put it on because oh it's
fresh as hell and it feels really nice
and it keeps me warm at the same time so
just in general a whole new attire of
clothing is definitely necessary so this
is this is step one like a boss but I
need a cigar in my hand and just delight
it
and you know not listen to anybody's
questions
another really special one for me
is a photo of me and my mom from 2010
and stated in the back it's all blue now
because I kept it in my jeans in high
school like all of freshman year no one
knew I think if anyone found out I
probably would've got bullied but I held
the picture of me and my mom just
everyday at school for the beginning
because it was the first time I was
really stepping outside of the Bronx and
like not being around family so I felt
like if I had this in my back pocket I
felt close to my mama close to my family
so she said to the best son in the world
I am extremely proud of you do your
thing baby you got this she was saying
do your thing because I was about an
audition for the high school that I went
to I was 13 years old and his car
LaGuardia High School and this is
intense audition process you have to go
through so she gave this to me and I got
into every school audition for that yet
with this in my pocket so yeah very
essential a baseball cap specifically
champion because champions been fired
these days but baseball caps are very
essential to me for several reasons one
if I don't have my brush I have to put a
hat on because my hair gets so wild so I
have just it just swags you out and
makes you the dope and cool plus lately
I've been getting weird stares from
people from across the street or just
from across the way for me I'll be at an
airport sitting down as someone's like
looking at me like
and so that's when the Hat goes from
like here sit down here
I don't know longer the stair goes it
gets lower she keeps looking it's just
straight up down here but you can't do
that with like this bucket hat or a
bandana you'll have to have a baseball
cap and so baseball caps major essential
my beats headphones music just a huge
part of my life I am obsessed with music
that makes me feel better it makes me
think clearer and like I said I make my
own music so when I make my own music I
feel like it's medicine and therapeutic
for me I just stay with my beats on all
the time like I just realized why I was
posting my stories the other day I
posted a story with my beats headphones
on and I realized it was like the tenth
story post in a row where I had my Beats
headphones oh it looks like I'm just
listening to music 24/7 which is
probably true so essential another
essential for me is um this medallion
that Korey wise gave me Korey wise if
you don't know who he is he's the man I
portrayed and the nufix show when they
see us and the first day I got to meet
him was at a table read and I read the
script out right in front of him and I
looked at him and he was crying his eyes
up he's a man who was falsely imprisoned
for years and so hearing the words of
the script made him cry and made
emotional and I remember coming up to
him like just speechless like I don't
know what to say or what to do but I
didn't have to say anything because what
he did was he took the medallion off of
his neck and he put it on mine and he
was like you're Korey wise now you're
the king now that moment spoke volumes
to me especially prior to shooting the
show I think it pushed me and motivated
me a lot and then it went way beyond
just the show for me wearing that
medallion gives me strength and courage
and makes me feel like I could be as
strong as he was through the time that
he was falsely imprisoned so I like to
keep it on me if I if I don't get the
chance to wear it I keep it on my
dresser and I just um it's a great
reminder that you could be way stronger
than you
could be you know what eyes it was
definitely extremely important because I
felt like I got to tell a lot of stories
of the folk that lived across the street
from me or above me or below me or
wherever this story is so prominent in
New York and the kind of story that you
see in when they see us happens every
day
especially in New York City so it's a be
a native New Yorker be able to share
this plight with with other New Yorkers
is definitely a blessing and I'm glad I
did it
[Music]